this is francis ellis
used to be from barcelona sports
before he made fun of the dead
uh and now where are you if people like
you
and want more of your thing
where can they find it yeah if if
someone goes my sister was just murdered
and i want you to get her
where can they get you where can they
hire you to do a roast of the dead
uh on on my podcast lovely it's called
oops the podcast oops the podcast this
is julio guys targeting back to yeah
yeah oops the podcast and social media
wise if they want to find you uh francis
ellis you'll find me on you'll find em
twitter take it away this song's amazing
thanks tim
cop pulled me over and asked why i was
speeding
i said i'm headed to the mountain for a
big day of skiing
he said i figured it was that from the
skis on your rack and then we both kind
of chuckled as he handed me back
my license registration told me try to
slow down we've got a lot of people
speeding through the stretch of our town
i promised that i would have said i
understood
and i always try my best to drive the
way that i should
he said goodbye enjoy the slopes and i
drove off down the road but when i got
around the bend i put the pedal to the
floor and when i finally arrived i was
greeted by a sight that made me shiver
and quiver and shake with fright
cause the line at the chairlift was 50
people long by the time i took my first
run all the powder was gone
all because some local cop had to flex
on me i'm just another victim
of brutality
brutality
it can happen to you if it happened to
me
i understand the nuances
of brutality
the winter is a time of darkness
when the sun goes down early and
everyone is heartless the days are short
and the nights are long and you'll wake
up with the feeling that it's all going
wrong when you feel like you're stuck in
a hole
and your brain starts to tell you it
can't take anymore and you no longer
care to learn what lies around the bend
so you start to think of ways to bring
your life to an end don't
instead
take a trip to tulum
find a beach in turks and caicos
snorkel la lagu
find that good wheat in jamaica
buy a house in southampton tim get that
going put your worries on the shelf
the purpose of mlk weekend is to utilize
your wealth
spend it on yourself
there's no price on mental health
don't kill yourself
[Music]
and i feel it too and i'm here for you
online all the time every day around the
world a woman gets robbed she makes 30
less with the same exact job she endures
the horny glances the delusional
advances guys like hi my name is francis
from the toxic male mob but the time has
now come to bring the wage gap to an end
time to rip down these structures that
were only built for men time to take a
wrecking ball to the ancient patriarchy
say your boss sent you a dick pic at the
holiday party
[Music]
i'm a [ __ ] ally
i know just what you're going through
and i feel it too and i'm here for you
online all the
[Music]
he time they their animals are friends
not food jada pink it's lack of hair and
me too save ukraine put a stop to asian
hatred microplastics overfishing
bloggers who joke about missing women
man spreading on public transit leah
thomas you penn swimming
n double acp order family separation
joe rogan's misinformation spreading
fears of vaccination cultural
appropriation louis ck's masturbation me
me look at me
i'm so full of empathy i'm on the right
side of history just like and share my
tweet tweet tweets like a-l-l
i'm a [ __ ] ally
i know just what you're going through
and i feel it too and i'm here for you
online all the time
[Music]
thank you
francis alice everybody we love that
thank you so much thank you for changing
your life
thank you for changing your life and
realizing that there's a lot of good
that can be done yes yes there's a lot
of good that can be done and you're
doing it i'm trying man yeah i didn't
have a choice no you're trying and
that's important yeah you know beautiful
thank you so much go find this guy on
social media go listen to his podcast
francis ellis thank you so much brother
see you guys